okay Plus and welcome to this video Wow
ok yeah probably just develop for IM
this is a somewhat this is a liability
to spawn let's see what is he trying to
do if i go queen to be 3 for example not
sure about it though
so 94 maybe who yeah couldn't be three
is just a bit is a bit strange yeah it
didn't it didn't play that well I mean
he has a far more active position than
he should have should have plagued III
probably prevent him from playing you
for in the first place yeah that would
have been good or at least better and
then the game
yeah it's a crazy move but it is prof
this is dangerous definitely dangerous I
mean my beach might be strong might be
strong okay so i can take the night he
takes one g three
I don't see a maid I just don't look h2
maybe am I mean it is it is dangerous
this one no I didn't didn't expect that
move at all hmm okay yeah but it just
makes some sense for sure cannot go back
can maybe take it Bishop takes Queen
takes check King edge one Bishop d6 then
mated on edge tomb good times go two
times yeah why did I allow me for them
how idiotic just played III and he's
just has a bad position maybe five the
square of this this is not not quite
good young okay anyway anyway
okay so 94 he's happy with the exchange
well yeah Queen age three
now you should just take the material
and win check oops mol slip yeah that's
very lucky of course well i'm giving
away points like that honest i'm all the
time so might as well get something back
at one point yeah very very bad i just i
just have to play d3m and this isn't any
good just do three instead of allowing
this I'm sorry just this instead of
allowing you form he just loses time
with the Queen and he will lose more
time I played this a three before and
the queen is in trouble down I mean I
just played the two quick castles and
then he formed is annoying now he's get
some scanning some space down in the
center the engine wants to play d3 which
is probably a good idea the way I played
it was really passive and can this was
very brutal but very very dangerous the
computer likes it and even h3 the
computer likes but it says also that
this wins the me ending yeah my
intention was this move but it's just a
winning attack
Kevin and for also loses 94 now is what
the engine gives no the check check yeah
there are things like that yeah okay no
argument there i was totally lost of
course check and tlk yes if it takes it
okay I mean I have some horns for the
exchange but two points but I have
absolutely no development so I've lost
him yeah I very lucky win by mouth slip
it's a it's a shame I just canceled too
quickly just d3 and white has a very
nice position it's really an offside
piece on 85 okay well thanks for
watching